R
>>PA C-SSN'ME ACARINTO HISVRY T
INCONT NSUE.OW
NU YOCAIND THEL FULULCH SED
EO
W TRHEKEEENDN O YROUAMRO PGR
GU ORT APA C-SORG/STORY.
♪
>>IN FLYGES WTCR ASOS THE
PAICC,FI VSI PERENTDE AND
RMRS. NHAICRDEGONIX B TANIRHE
TAKECOHE TM LYLEMPTEDRO AUNHE T
O
D.RL
THRIR FSTNAES DTI WONTIAS
MA.LA
EUS BY C OITAPALFHE T
IPPHILNEPISAS W,E LIKHE TT RES
HEOF TRYOU CNT,SE TEN WHIT
TEEXCINNTME O THE EVE OF ARE GAT
A
ONTIALEB CEL,TIRAONHE 1H0T
ANYRSVEAR OND IENNCDEE.
♪♪
>> ONHE T AONERFTNO OFY JUL 3RD,
MRDAN.  MRSXONINDE LAND
FOINOWGRI BEFER CS,ONEMIE
RC. MRGAIAPACC AOMHEEDNI T
HOREDST GUE TSORE WHE
IDPRESTEN MND AMO. RSRAAAN
WAM. TEDHE- AITEDHE T
ISTH,IN AGA M W,ASANE ORTH
A
ISREME V.IT
A WITASREOLN D --IOUNN  A WMAR
NUNREIOENET BWELD ODSRI FEN
.ON
THENGOR MNI OF THE 4TH OF
LYJU, AAY D GSRILOOUO TH BOT
LLFIINIL FIP AOSND ANSRIMECA,
XO. MRNI--N
IBNA[IUD]LE
ARETH MRTYSE WHOAM NE INOS KWN
ONIL MLI WSHOSHHE CRIOMRE FED.
ETHUM COLNEN MOMT B
UGROHT
RIMEMO TESLLO ARESE,NTOR FT I
♪
Y>> BSSER PMIFNIO OHE
PR TENIDT,HEE HUGWD CROAS W
WEALLO TDOURGERDOR FWA AT
'SRAPADE, EHE T BTEETR TO HREA
ETHSSDD ARE V OFEICRE PDESINT
XONIN.
>> IAVE WEDNEITSS MYANHOU FRT
F
ULYAR P
ESAD.
IAV HEN SEEESAR PADIT WAN MY
FL
TSOAND AAN MYDS BAN.
ITN ALLY ME, LIF I HEVEAV N
R
SEEN P AADARE TO EQU TALHENE O
ETH PINLIHIPP PESUT ON.OD TAY
SHE[CERND ALAE]US
>> WEE N ITH SITUNEDTETASN I
ROUAR ELYEA YRS HADHE T PRO
L
OFUR OIE TOR WSHOE WERTI SLL
YALOLO T AEI FORGNE. RUL
UTSHNI BR YOUEMRO PBLHEN I T
PHNEIPILPI WSAS A FARREATER
ONE.
ATHETYHOUTRI OFOU YROV GTNMEREN
CWASGELLHAENHEBYD  T.AW HKS
NOAN MY T OFSEEB RS,EL AS
U KW,NO SER WEPLIMEPL PEOE.
PRHELYAB T MRE GATYORAJITF O
THER WE.
RTHEIEA LRSDE.AED L BRASTYY
TOU Y AOLSNO KWT  THAONAMG THE
ERLEADS WEREEN M WE WHOEROT N
YTRULINIL FIP.OS
THUSCAE EY ODHE TIR FSTIR
ANLEALGI T NCEOTOHE TLI PHIINPPE
GONTRNVEME T B,UT TOHE
TERIISTIC, RSHLUTESGNOR FEI
LOIDEO OGYFMU COMSTNI
ALLOCONITIS ILIERMPIAS.ST
HADAN W DT YIDOUBOO D AUT IT?
HIDAN TS, TOE, MS I ONEF OHE T
SEAGRT ORITOESFS THIUB REPCLI
ODANT TNEHA SULHODEOL TD AND
E
LLLDTO AVE ORHE TOR W.LD
TIT'SERUHA TT YOUSE UD MITARY
O
ERCHE WRESAEC NES IRYNEA DNGLI
HETHWI T HKSAW.
BU YOULS AO DIDHIOM SET
NGPE
APRHSVE ENOR MEMP ITANT
YO
UEM REDOV THEICOL PITALND
ECICOMSAU CSE OONDIF SCNTTE.
AN
HIIND  TS EORFFT,R YOU
ESIDT P AYELAD L PDIEANGT.AR
DAN FORHI TS,EL BVEIEE, MHE T
PR HENIDT WASON THE AIRATNIO
F
HE T WLEHO FERELD WOR.
USPP[ALA
NO KW THA TTREHEREHO TSEHO W
TFEELTHAEN FRIEUYDL NYALTRIT
TO
TRDWASHE KMLREINND A PINEKG
MAAR VY.
UT BUYO TNO KWSREHE IN ALD O
PR
AEROVB, I INDTST THA HE
WO WH--HIT TEV DT MILUSAV HE
LOA NG.PO SON
TH CSTMUOMNIHAS VEEE BN
LERUTHAR TSSOWHEPL PEO
F
NTHE TIOATNSYHEAV HEFENG EUL
H
EYE HAVO NEM MIEORS OME FFORR
FAO,RS NESIN KDNS FORSE THO
WHRY TO  TBEDLRI FEN
ARE AOL CDNDAL CNGLACUTI,H
DAN THOSEHO WEE FL TTHA CHE TY
N
ANOUTM TVEEURMHE ARE TAKG A
FUFEARLK. RIS
OPWE HE TLLTHA A-HE T - OF
ASL -  -ALATETH N ONSIOF AASI
WIER UNDANSTD OURTT AUDITE
RDTOWACTOL CLEECEIV S
ITUR.
MAAND  IYAY ST AHI TSNT POI I
AP PIAECTELATIARCUHEYRL TT FAC
H
H WATITHE TN RAI CINOMG DN,OW
Y MSOAN OFOU YTI S WLILND STA
ERTHEND AN.IS LTE
YMANK T IHA YOUOR FTE LISNGNI SO
ENPATINDY,TL AAY M - I-ND A
IYAY S T A YOUSAS W THEAS CEMA
THSYEE ARGO A, MXO. RSNINDN A
I N BVEEEYEE DPLCH TOU BEDY
THELCWEOMT THAE WAV HE
IVCEEDLL AVE OR YROURYOU CNT.
I THASTRU T TTHE YRSEAHEAD
LLEE SHE TEP R OLIUBCHEF T
PHSPIIPNEAK ME ERENVE GERAT
SSOGPRREHEN I TEX NTEN T YRSEA
AN I L TNHETAS. TEN
[CDS ERANUSPP ALAE]
>>HEEX NTICAY D VE PNTSIREDE
NNIXOEDIS VIT-HE T -
[I]IBUDLE
ITG LONT IL SENNGUIT WAI RHSEM
A MEM TIAORLO TVE BHERAEN M WHO
EDFEDENDHI TSSLAN FORESTRS.
A'SON B BDWEETENWO TIO NAT,NS
TRFO IAS WEREFIHA TT LLSIN POT
DCAME ARI -NS- FOSIPILINND A
AM
IDBY S IES.FGH ANDIE DDID S
UNETH TASLNE WLS AODOU TREY B
TH
ERLEE ADHOS W SREDID VIV
PRIMSSIESONF OTS ITO HISCRI
PA
ERAS W HEHA TIN LTIVGUA QERRTS
HADEE BNVI PRODDEOR FHE TIR FST
PIILPHIPRESNE P,DESINTAN CND A
WITASE HERHAT GSERENAL MAC
THARURND ARIAI WNWTGHDAN MNE
THTRREI S
EGATY.
THEDERE PSI -NT-EDLA PNNHE TIR
STGYTE.
THDERE PSI ANTDANRRGES THIRI T
T
EQHE T RSTUEF O MON NR.IXHO W
WI TEDO SEEIMOR F HLFSE THE
SHHARDATS IPTH - THE-
OF
CRDEMOADYAC HXP EEDIEERNC.
♪
>> THEEX NT DAYHE T NLIOATNA
SES CPEBLU SALCILYDO AOREDRN F
THE VISITSORM FRONGAS WHINTO
TCABEMEE VHEIC PNTSIREDE'S
FIP SLTOOR BEFE HELE F
TWO
GHSION GE.
TH - TOON.AI SGO
TISOORO PDEVID AONEU RNI.
NGRI AF HAL HROUER INTEWVI, HE
SEPRIMES TDHE NSMEWEN BYIT WH
HIS FSSNKRANEN ISSIS DCUGIN
VENTCOROIARSLSSUE
WAST THAIL MARITY BOUESAS WLD
T -BE-OLEIT THE T MYITILAR
BAD WOS ULBE RETNEDO THE T
LAATR TETHNI MOR T INGNHE OR
KEWAF O AONON MSO VAI RN,EIC
ENESPRIDNDT ARS. XONINRR AEDIV
HEIN T CITAPAL OF UTHIE VAMTN.
S.U.SAMB AASRERDO FRIDECK
HAREIN,RT REPS SERENT TOFHE
PR AENIDTND AHR TGONF O
VISENAETMEENIT CIZSET GREHEED TM
N. NOTHERLACEER WEHE T
TXONINS ASEO E BIGREHA CNG
THHE TIROURE PVIS VITIS.
THENHI TS HAN LD IEE BNTHN E
TH
FESRO O W.AR
ITDATOY  AAS W PLCEEAFUND A FERE
REICBL.
IDEIL RGINNT IOAI SN,GO SNSIG
TOVERHEOR WLD TEDTIESFIO THE T
SHIEFRNDTN VIPIEAM TEE FLS
D
ATHENRIMECAEEO PPLND AHE TIR
EL RTEECDNTREEPSE.IVATES
THNEAP HPE B TDO AEE TIM O
F
TIONALOI REJNGCI.
HEEREVYWRE TREHEER WEEO PEPL
YICARRNGRSAN BNE,INAR MCHNG
CE
IOBRLEATHEOFN  TDEC SON
ARVENIRSHEOFY  TRE PY.DESINC
[C
ANERHES LA ADPPE]
♪
>>ANHO TUSDSREAT GHEOND THE
USACSPIOBEAW LN HEREFO T
ENESPRID PALTIACALEO TER CHE THE
BLPUICND A THEDERE PSIN WNTHE
MRNNI. XOTOAM CE E BVEEC REI
Y
YTHENGOUAT N CN'IOSEFHI
EX
IVUTE.
ER[CHE AANS DE]LAPPUS
♪
HE T TWO LDEEARSRRON CFEDEEDD
FOR HANOUND A AAL HF.
NIMR. NXO EDENXTDERE PDESINT
EI
ERNHSEOW'SARST PLSOERNA
COTITURALAELS,ON WNE ELAR BDY
MAA N ANDIS HEOPLADHO W H
THWNON ASTHIISNGPI STRI
THWOHUG TIF DCULTRS YEA.
♪
T>> ASI PRENTDEIE DSM'
IN,TITAONHAT TYHE WTEN
OUNDEID AHA TEDNKM THE FOR THE
SPNIIDND UHITY WCH HEEL F
SISPREONR E BLFOUCETH S TCEHE
NA HONADIE ACHD.VE
LS AO TNKHAEDHE TDNI UTE
ST THRGHTS IIC VE
IDPRESORTEN FTS IP HEL O NOTYNL
TOIE VAMTN, B TUTO TIR EHENT
E
OFREEORR W.LD
MAES RNSPOE,AN MYON NIX- -N I
SPSEON,ICR. M NAIONKS SD
AM
ICERAAS W --IX NONAI SD
WAICERA S PUDRO.
, I TEENDD,OE BTN VIE'SAMRI FDEN
ANLL AY.
OTHEHIGHOI PNTNT POI,HE T
U.PRIC VE TIDESENEEC BAMHE T
FI
TRSUE GAK SSTPEER ERVEIT INV
TO BEAPPROREFEHI TSAR PTY
RFO N MR.ONIX,HI TSLERI PVIGE
HA
DPE SALCIFIIG SNINCCAE, FOR
[APPUSLAE] LEGTOLAR.VE SERDAN MR
TO THE RNTREEPSE OIVATESF THE
ETVINASEMEPL PEOE,E H EEDREXPSS
HIDM ANATIRIOOR FHE T
ACMELIMPSHT TNTHA HADDAR MKE
THIR FSTWO TEA YRS OF
PRY ENIDTTS,YE'SA' MAM
STMIADNITION- DM'IES
AD
RANIMIST
ONTI.
AIHE SE HDER ITH SNOU VTNIEAM
THIT MILTANAR MCH OFOMMUSM
BHASNEE AAL HD,TEND ARO FMS T
WFREELDORIV DEREDRE GAT
ATSPINIRN.IO
LA[APPE]US
TOSIVIT HE RUGEFEE
REMETTSELEA ANTREAS WTH ANO
RTOPPOITUNYOR F N MR.OONIX T SEE
ETH EDIRAXTORRYNA JOBTN VIEAM IS
IINDOGNAB REHINITILAT TGHE
DSNDHUREF O TUSAN WHOLE F
DH
ENIOM CMUSTOR N.TH
GBEIN ARAT FHESE HIME,LF H
ESPEALLYNJ EEDOYEE MHENGTI T
DRCHIL.EN
♪
THELD EORS,ER FHE TTSAR PENFOO A
THE AGE WHO'D UIV GENP ALLY THE
HAES TO PECA CSTMUOMNINYYR TAN
ANNIV H IAN A LHAD TT
OFD RE--IVND A L IEN A LDAN
THEDFF OERER LIB.TY
VTHEREEIC P MDESINTET THE RANOM
A
THK HICTSRI PESAT- - CLIC
ASTIESNDSTH OER WHOAD H
WOED AON LGFL SEL TSLESY
MA
S TKEHIP CAM AGIV LIN AND
GRGIN TNG.
♪
>> HEAW S N FMARMEQU EIPNT
MAVAILLEHR TNIGHOU UDTE
ATSTESSS AE.TAISNC
SHE AAWYEE DPL RUSIGELIOPL PEOE
STOOL AHEERFT TIRINLE BSSYG B AW
WSHBIOP WHOAS A R.UGEFEE
ASIT WN AGENF UOR
ABTTLE
RIEXPEORCEEN FICHE T V
PR
IDEN
T  FHEEL WHEASSSIT WNE HGINEER
ONHEF O T GREAT SRITOES O
HEUTAS AT AA,SI THE SRYTOF OSO
SOHTN VIE'S FHTOR F
M EEFRDODAN ARET BTE LOREIF F
AL
L.
♪
N OHE T ENING OFUL JY
T,
VICERE PDESINT AND MRS-.- JYUL
ICH,7T VREE PDESINTND A
NMRS.RRONIX ANEDIV IN.AI SGO
ETH FORGNEI MRISINTEND A- -
[I
LEUDNAIB
AMO THE TIR FSTHECO WELME
.THEM
♪
LS>> AO GDHEATRE TO GETRE THE
ALRSPEON RNTREEPSE OIVATESF
PRENTIS ERHOENWE WEER
IMANRTTNE CHIOVSE GTNMEREN
ALFIOFCI ASNDRSEM MBEF THE
OMDIPLICATOR C.PS
♪
THEIT CAP OALFNAAT NIOSTLINO T
INCHA.
THE XT DAYE H CEDFEONRR WITH
IDPRESHATEN CNG KAIHE AKERFT
GI
IMNGVI H A LTEETRRO FM
IDPRESSET ENEI TOWNHERTHA
LYROSTNGEA RURSSEDHI C'SNA
ADLEERND ATS IEO PE.
ETHWO T SENTETASMOS PED FOREW NS
MEMECARA
N.♪
♪
>>R. MIX NON SUMDHEP U T
CO
OENNTTIR TFHEAL TKS I AN
BRTE SFTANTME.
I JTUSAD HON A CEREFENCIT WH
THDERE PSINTREIT WH ORDGA THE
TIRELAETSON BHEENWE T GENEROVNM
F
NIHE T U SDTE ATETASNDHE T
MEVEGORN T ONTFUB RHEEPCLI OF
INCHA,ND AN I TONSHI CEREFENCE W
USDISCDSEHE TUA MUTLRO P
EMS
ANDHE TUA MUTL DGEANRSHI WCH WE
O
IRONFNT TNHELD WOR.
THER GOVOFENNMT NIHE T UDTE
ST
NDESAT AEOHE T PFEPL OHE T
UN SEDTETAS SNDTAYIR FMLIT WH
THNMOV GERFTEN OHE TUB REPCLI
HIOF C T ANANDHEEO PFEPL O THE
RE OBLPUICFHI CNAIN AGAST
COISUNTRE AGG IIOSSNN AASIND A
E
OTRTS PAREF  OTHLD WOR.
AASTES RULF OHI TSREON CFEE,NC
AIMUR SET THAHE TL WREILE BO N
T DOUB TINHEIN MDSPE OF LEOP
TOUARND WORHA TTUR OWO T
IEUNCOTR ASND OURWO T PPLES
STET TDOGRHESTGA AIN THE
CO DANR WCHHIEA THRNSTE
EOEEFR PROEPL AHEDUN TOR W,
THRAN DGEF OOM CNIMUSTIAMP IERL
O
ISNILOALM.
>> BINIDGOKAC THE TPO AIR,RT
E VISI PCERENDNTDE AISTY PAR
WELE HAI BDY TDSUSHOANF O
INOUE,ES YNGND ALD O,HO W
LID THE S OEETRTSF TPEAII.
[C
ANERHES LA ADPPE]US
♪
AOS IMPUAGIN GRDF OON HOR
ATWAS IRHE T ARTPO TAYO PHE TIR
COY'TRSES R TCTPESTHO E
THESE WEERRA CCKTI CONENNGTS OF
ONNATIISALT'SHI CNA
RBSUPEIN-TLYRAHT FEDIG
GIN
ESFORC.
♪
AN UNEDECXPTEEL DAY C BSEAUD
ETHUTLO BWO OFN A AEPLIRANIR TEY
O
DPOSTNE THE DARTU.
R AFTERRTFUHEAL TKSIT WHNE CHISE
N
. UD.SFF O,IAICLSIC VE
IDPRESTENND A MXO. RSNINEM '
EDPLANOR FANHA TILK SDIC HRSOU
SHIBENDE EDCHUL S--IX HOU
BENDULCH SEDE.
♪
T ILOAS W CSE TOID MGHNITHE WN
THEYRR AEDIVN IOKAN BGK.
OFME PHERIIS MINRTE AND HIS
FEEDRE GET THE WHIT
HE T
ITTRADLIO CORRMHA FHI WCH
EITHR LSDAN IOU FAM
S.
WTHEYLSEER AOREET BEDYHE T
S.U.AS AMBDOSAR, MWEAXLLHO BISP,
N
OMDIPL CICATPSOR.OHE T
♪
>> LEADING H GSTUESNT IO A
IOCEREPT RNM OOATRTIR APO,
E
EPRIMTEIN MISED ARDD ALOR FMA
LC
WEE OIS HWN O.
♪
>> ASHE TEI FORGNTEIN MIS ARND
ROTHENI DIGRITAESOO L ODKEN, THE
R
IEEMREC RLEALD HOWML WAR H
HAD BNEEVEEC REIDGUR DIN HISWN O
TSIVITO ARICAUS JT THER YEA
,FOBERE A HETTEG RREHERE
WAE T'TIMUG ENOHO T EINERNTTA
SHIME ACARINRI FDSEN
APRIOPATY.EL
♪
>>N I,EP RLY THE UCE. .SVI
IDPRESSIT ENINHAEDST TT THE
ELCWEOMAS WH MUCOR ME TNHA
ADANTEUA, DE H EEDREXPSSEE DP
EFGRAT TNEULSSOTHA SY MAN O
NDAITHLA L'SEAHORSDE SEDUL B
NONDKI EOHUG T TNUR UPND AEE MT
HEMHI WNE H HADN BEEBL OEDIG TO
O
TME A SOAT L AENOU HR.
AIN DINGOO RPA PMREDRE FOR
THCCASN, THE MRI PMERISINTE
DIXR. M NON ANDHE TIR PTYAR
PA
OORTKF O A MUDHT NIG DNEINR,
--ONE GHID MNITR,IN DNE ONEOR ME
E AMEXPLOFANHA TILSD'
ALSPHOIT TY ITTO AMECAN
WIGOODLLSAMB AASR.DO
♪
O>>GAENC AINIXR. M NONEL HD A
PR
SESON CE.REFENC
HE UORERNDSCEDCAME ARION S'STRG
BAG INOFHE TEAOU STHST AASI
TRAN OTYRGN.ATIZIO
THNDNDLA AHE UTETE SDTAS,
HEEC DRELAD, WLDOUTI CNUE
TH
R EORTSOR FCO EMINOC
DE
ENLOVEPM ATNDLOC SIA
-BWELLONGEI S TT ALLAY M
LRSPUUEESIVN I PEACE AND
PPINS.
♪
T>>NHE A LASD- GOOROEBY FMHE T
MIMPRERISINTEEEF BOR HIS
URPADERT FEORTAAK PISN.
♪ MUCK.
AT LER TTHAER VYNI MOR,NG AS
FAIRCEORNS TRAEARTPO REDCH
KAI.CH
TW OFAK PSTAISN'OP TRSEM MBE
WEEDOMHE TSIX NONO TERNO ATH
TION.
♪
T>>HE 8THEG RENIMT PDVIRODEHE
NOHOR GRDUA.
EUT SAL TEE VOICRE PDESINT
INXONIN HE TBS AFCEEN OHE
PRINE M WTEISRASHO W AYWA IN
LO
ORONND FHE TOM CLTNWMOEAH
COER
CEEN.
WITH THEDNI UTETE STARG CSHA
ED'
ESFAAFIRF, I TICHE VE
TIDESENND ARS MNNI. XOET M
TMORE0NHA 5RSEM MBEF O THE
FONIGIP DCMALOTI.OR CPS
♪♪
>> CCHATYAS W A -THNOERHIAR KAC
WATH ANOLAER PCEO TAT GLY
ESIMPR PVIS CENTSIREDE.IX NON
THEER CAMANAMCC AINPAOMNYHEG T
VI PNTSIREDEOO TKHE TSEWS VIE
OFHEIT CSY'OO B
NGMI.
ATHEYRETIRA DMACIN REMRDE OF
STPAKINE'SAN ENDYRG A
TE
DEIOINRMAT
N.♪
♪
T>> AHE T PSIDEIALE,AL PAC
TEMOUNDAN RRSGE IN WTEHISUN TIC
R
AIDOVED CLOROLFU EORTOR
THTY PEARTHRO FM ENI UTE
DST
ESAT.
♪♪
ENS IID N MR.ONIXOS PH WEDIT
TH
SI PERENTDE ANDETAB CIN IF
MIERSTSER AFTRRON CFEITGIN WH
THEMN OAT MRSTEF OIT MARY A
C
OMONIC. AID
WHRSEIL MNNI. XOHATT WITH A
CHNGMIND AOURA GCISST FIR
.LADY
♪
EEF BOR LVIEANGHIAR KAC T,
ICS.U. VSI PERENTDEEDRA GNT
ROTANHERE PSS CNCFEONRE
UEHE T QIOSTNF OHM KAS,IR HEN
U TIDHE STENID HTETAS
PED
INDISTPAA/KIKS TANALR, O FLIAING
THATTH,  TUGROHHENI UTE UTENID
NAS.ON
IT WAST TSHISS PREREON CFEENC
THATEAR WDNEIN AGAST ANGEPCCTI
SOET
ID A.
THEMU COMSTNIRI PE,CE HAI SD,
COED B A REOPUN ARODHE TIR
S.NECK
DAIRO FMUS R CASILDOUPE SLLTS I
END.
AFR FROURS HOU INAR KHIAC,HE T
NSNIXONE P'LAAR DEPESDTE WT
THRDWAS TACAE PI OLFY.UR TKEO
ASIT WHT NIGVIHE WN SI PCERENTDE
DAN MXO. RSNINIV ARRTED A
RAANKA A'S.POIRRT
BOTHKE TURSY'SI PRENTDEND A HER
PRRIECO WELDME THE PERNASOL
SAEMISRY OF PNTSIREDE
EI
ERNHSEOW.
REETH P,DESINT WHOAL RECDLE
N'NI. XOOSS HPILITATYHE W HNE
TEVISIDNGAS WHIN,TOIS INSDTE
HEATTH T PIC VENTSIREDE HND AIS
EFEWI BERIS H PNASOLS.UE GST
[CNDSER AUSPP ALA
EEX NTHEAY D T WREEERE MORF O
COSTHENCHAETI MEESNGIT WH
NAORDIPL PRYEOE, ARI BEFHA CT
AWITHNG YOUSHUR TKI NSEW BOY
GHBROUT OUTIS HEE DPER INTNTES I
ICAMER AAND HISTIFF AECON FOR
IDPRESTEN EWEENISHO
EREES WLI FEEESNGT THA.TH
XO. MRNIIC NNOTEDWHVE ERY
E
WENTND A INEO PROEPL FMID WYEL
ENFFDIERTROAC BKG ADSUNND
ALTINAONRC AS.
♪
FNE O O THE MTOS IIVREMPSSE
MOFSNT O VREEIC PDESINT
NI
N'XOS I DAYNHE TUR TSHKI
CA WTAPIL HASIS LINAYG A W
H
HEAT T OOM TB TFHEND FOU PER OF
MORNY.UR TKE
NDOUERF OOD MNERY.UR TKE
ON SEECDHE HIGSTFF OOFIAICL
ITE THUNTE SEDTAER GSOVENNMT
AIDPANOL SEM STOUTALE HE T
ME ORYFNE O OFHE T MTOS
EXARRDAOINYEA LRSDE OFS THI
CE
URNTY.
♪
>>NGRI DVIAC BKGHHR TOU THEY CIT
N
TUTROE TOHEPO AIR,RTHE T
AMICANIC VERE P'SDESINT
RCMOTOEADPP STO IEDN C THETEENR
AOFNNC A HNTIE,ISTOCRIT PARF O
CANAR A.
AVISTH G--E AR ANKA.
E GISAV N MR.NCONIX OIN AEGA
TH
EPP OORTUOTYNI T TEE MTHE
.OPPELE
HEPPTEED OUTO T SKEHADS HAN
WI
Y MTHANSO PERNSHO WUI QLYCK
OUSURRISEDND HAR C.
♪
>>THE T A TPOIRRTREHEAS W ONE
FLASTYENRIDL T
CHOU.
PVICENTSIREDEND A.  MRSXONIN
AHAD SO PERLNAD- GOO FEBYMRO
LIPOCEIC OFFSER WHO HADOR ESCDTE
TH.
♪
>> AAL FINELAR FEWM FLROETH
F CHIE TOFHEIO NATLNASS ABLEMY
FRAND  TOMHE PMIREER FOR WMHO
XO. MRNIRI CNARES AED MSAGE TO
IDPRESISTEN ER.HOENWE
ENTHHE T PIC VENTSIREDENE P'SLA
EDTURNARES WTWDE ONCOR ME
VR
CTHE CITAPALITYND A OERTH
EYTURK T,THANTNC AIE LICD ANWHH
AIST SNC OEODO MNEROO T.
♪♪
>>N THETU SINNNGED MNEERITRAAN
NDISLAF OAL MRCLOA,HE T PNELA
STRIDPE BLYEF TOUE REF
CEDERE PSINT NONIXAS WEDRE GET
BY THE U..SMB ARSAASDO TO SPAIN
TD ANBYHE SNIPASHGNOR FEI
ERNIMIST.
♪♪
>> LTASLIEF RUENGP STO WAS
INUDRMA  T MHEID AC.ANTLTIBE
, THENAY11 DSFT AER TYHEAD H
LE VOM HE,ICERE P ADESINTND
IXS.MR N RONDURETNEO T
INWASHONGT.
AAR LGERO CWDEDRE GETM THE
INCLINUDAT SGENOR NNDANOL AHE T
ETSECRY AROF STETA.
ISAN HRITOCOU TR WASR. OVE
REESRASUNCF OAS E
WET-ST
NDFRIESHIPEEAD H BADN MEUN ARO
H
E,OR WLD ELLECSPIAY SIT WHIX
NA WONTISMHOHE T UNIDTETE STA
SS
RO PUDO TAL CLTN PAR IERNHE T
STLEGGOR FRE FOMED.
♪